[Musica]
mai prima nella storia l'innovazione ha
promesso così tanto a così tanti in così
breve tempo
innovazione ne sentiamo parlare ormai
tantissimo
l'innovazione più che mai in questo
momento può cambiare le nostre vite ma
sappiamo veramente cosa significhi cos'è
un innovazione
cosa vuol dire fare innovazione ebbene
se cercate su internet
come ho fatto io troverete un infinità
di diverse definizioni di questa parola
ma tutte hanno in comune un concetto
l'innovazione a che fare con
l'applicazione pratica di un'invenzione
dunque inventare significa ideare
formulare nuove idee per un prodotto
innovare significa trasformare queste
idee queste invenzioni in dei prodotti
commerciabili e voglio farvi un esempio
questo che ho tra le mani è un puntatore
laser e bene dietro questo oggetto
apparentemente tanto semplice si
nasconde in realtà una storia di
innovazione che è estremamente lunga e
altrettanto affascinante la tecnologia
laser infatti fu scoperta degli anni
cinquanta fu inventata negli anni 50
il brevetto risale al 1960 di proprietà
dei bears americani e fu il risultato di
ricerche scientifiche estremamente
lunghe e complesse
pensate che se non si sarebbe potuto
scoprire il laser senza le ricerche
scientifiche sulla natura della luce
fatte da plan che einstein
all'inizio del novecento e bene ma dopo
l'invenzione del laser dovete aspettare
ancora molti anni prima di veder
comparire nelle nostre vite
il laser pensate che risale al 1974
la prima scansione di un codice a barre
di un prodotto all'interno di un negozio
si fa con la tecnologia laser e se
volete aspettare ancora qualche anno per
la prima installazione di fibre ottiche
siamo nella città di chicago
1977 ebbene oggi le telecomunicazioni
funzionano con la fibra ottica che
utilizza al laser e se dovete aspettare
gli anni 80 per veder comparire lettore
cd utilizzate e bene potrei fare
un'infinità di altri esempi oggi con
laser
oggi il laser si utilizza medicina per
la chirurgia si utilizza nell'industria
per fare il taglio di precisione o in
estetica per la depilazione la rimozione
i tatuaggi
il laser è dato a far parte della nostra
vita quotidiana con oggetti anche molto
semplici come questo puntatore ebbene
arrivare ad un invenzione è un percorso
lungo e faticoso serve tanta ricerca
scientifica ma tradurre delle idee delle
ricerche scientifiche delle invenzioni
in un innovazione in un prodotto è
altrettanto complesso è un percorso
lungo e faticoso ma può cambiare le
nostre vite e ci riguarda più da vicino
di quanto potete immaginare gli ho fatto
l'esempio del laser ma oggi voglio
raccontarvi un'altra storia di
innovazione una storia che stiamo ancora
scrivendo con la punta di una matita la
grafite infatti fu scoperta nel xvi
secolo furono dei pastori inglesi fine
sono conto per la prima volta che
c'erano delle pietre apparentemente
metalliche che se strofinate sulle loro
pecore potevano lasciare un segno nero
fu una vera rivoluzione per il tempo
perché gli permetteva di segnare le
pecore poter distinguere nel gregge ma
fu solo qualche anno dopo che due
italiani
i coniugi berna cotti ebbero un'idea
brillante ritagliarono questa pietra la
grafite e la inserirmi dei tubetti di
legno fu la nascita della matita come la
conosciamo oggi
e questa è già di per sé è una storia di
innovazione incredibile dopo più di
cinquecento anni promette ancora di
cambiare il mondo
se andassimo vedere la grafica infatti
molto molto molto da vicino ci
accorgeremmo che è stratificata e
composta da una pila di milioni
milioni di strati uno sopra l'altro come
un libro composto tante pagine
appoggiata una sopra l'altra
il singolo strato il singolo foglio del
nostro libro di grafite è costituito da
atomi di carbonio che sono legati tra
loro geometrie esagonale a nido d'ape
rompere questo foglio è praticamente
impossibile ma il legame che c'è tra uno
strato e successivo cioè tra una pagina
e l'altra invece estremamente debole
quindi è possibile staccare uno strato
dagli altri in maniera abbastanza
semplice questo è anche il motivo per
cui la nostra matita scrive quando
andiamo a sprecarla contro un pezzo di
carta quello che succede che alcuni
pacchettini di questi strati si staccano
dal blocco di grafite e rimangono sul
pezzo di carta lasciando un segno nero
la matita scrive ma si dovette aspettare
fino al 2004 perché due scienziati in
manchester con un esperimento
apparentemente molto semplice dopo anni
e anni di ricerca scientifica riuscirono
per la prima volta a isolare un singolo
strato di grafite
il grafene quel venerdì sera quei due
scienziati non poteva game avevano
disposizione solamente dello scotch un
po di grafite forse vi chiederete beh
perché non usare un temperino l'idea che
la grafite andava rotta in maniera
estremamente controllata non andava
rotta in tutte le direzioni
bisognava attaccare uno strato dagli
altri senza rompere il singolo strato
quindi con un pezzo di scotch e
incominciare ad attaccare attaccare
attaccare e staccare incominciare a
staccare questi strati di grafite uno
dall'altro e finalmente riuscirono a
ottenere uno singolo e osservando con un
microscopio e caratterizzarlo pensate
che questi esperimenti gli valsero il
premio nobel della fisica nel 2010
andiamo a vedere un po più da vicino
perché è così interessante questo
grafene abbiamo detto è un simbolo
strato di grafite un tappeto di atomi di
carbonio dal materiale che spesso o
sottile che dir si voglia solo quanto un
atomo non esiste nulla di più sottile ed
è considerato un po il materiale delle
meraviglie il materiale dei superlativi
è un po il migliore in tutto
pensate che il materiale più
e conosciuto non esiste nulla che abbia
una resistenza meccanica pari a lui e
addirittura a una resistenza meccanica
superiore a quella dell'acciaio e pur
essendo così forte è estremamente
flessibile
pensate potrei costruire un amaca grande
quanto un millimetro quadro quanto la
punta di una matita e capace di
sostenere quattro chili quattro chili su
un'amaca grande quanto la punta di
questa matita ed è un materiale
estremamente leggero un grammo è
sufficiente per coprire un'area di 2.630
metri quadri per darvi un'idea per
coprire la superficie di un campo da
calcio basterebbero tre grammi 3 grammi
e pur essendo così leggero e sottile è
praticamente completamente impermeabile
non ci sono sostanze elementi
praticamente che lo possano attraversare
ed è il miglior conduttore di calore
conosciuto praticamente può trasportare
il calore meglio di qualsiasi altro
materiale è uno dei migliori conduttori
di elettricità trasporta corrente in
maniera estremamente efficace e
trasparente lascia che la luce lo
attraversa ma la cosa più interessante
sono quei puntini che vedete in fondo
perché molte altre sono le carte che il
potrei elencare vi e molte altre ancora
e quelle che ancora hanno scoperte
pensate che tali sono le potenzialità di
questo materiale che gli scienziati
europei si sono messi insieme sono
riusciti a ottenere il più grande
finanziamento europeo di sempre grafene
flagship l'europa messo a disposizione
un miliardo di euro per un progetto di
10 anni per studiare il grafene le sue
potenziali applicazioni e con
l'obiettivo di trasformare tutto ciò in
dei prodotti commerciali
l'europa si è unita per riuscire e
cercare di competere con paesi come la
cina che sono molto più avvezzi a fare
innovazione tecnologica
ora la domanda è tanta attenzione tante
bellissime proprietà cosa se ne potrà
mai fare di questo materiale
e voi da di qualche esempio
infine abbiamo detto un materiale
flessibile è un materiale trasparente
che conduce elettricità molto bene
ebbene se ne potrebbe fare un
elettronica flessibile indossabile
trasparente
pensate di poter fare con grafene i
vostri schermi degli schermi nei vostri
cellulari e quindi mettere fare un primo
passo verso la costruzione di smartphone
completamente flessibile che poi potrei
pensare di arrotolare intorno un braccio
e quindi come un braccialetto indossarlo
ma non solo sembra fantascienza ma
immaginate di prendere un foglio di
plastica trasparente leggero che potrei
arrotolare e mettere in borsa ma sul
quale potrai leggere le news o guardare
un film questa stessa tecnologia si può
utilizzare anche per i vestiti
pensate che un giorno le nostre
magliette potrebbero diventare degli
oggetti intelligenti capaci di agire
come dei sensori e quindi per esempio
monitorare il nostro battito cardiaco
durante attività fisica e al tempo
stesso è in grado di raccogliere questi
dati e trasferirli per esempio il mio
cellulare ma non solo riconoscete tutti
lì in alto un'auto elettrica
ebbene tutti sappiamo che ci piacerebbe
poter utilizzare queste auto elettriche
per ridurre i consumi ridurre le
emissioni però sapete anche che in
questo momento per ricaricare le
batterie dei vostri cellulari o dei
vostri computer ci vogliono delle ore
ebbene grazie al grafene potremmo
costruire delle batterie molto più
efficienti capaci di accumulare più
carica e di caricarsi in maniera
estremamente veloce per esempio in dieci
minuti
il grafene anche un materiale abbiamo
detto il leggero e resistente
pensate di poterlo combinare con dei
materiali compositi cioè costruire dei
nuovi materiali leggeri e resistenti
potremmo utilizzarli per esempio per
farci delle aerei o dei satelliti o
qualsiasi tipo di veicolo rendendolo
quindi estremamente leggero più leggero
meno consumi e meno costi sembra
la scienza ma non siamo così lontani
oggi il grafene viene prodotto a livello
industriale
una delle tecniche più comuni ci
permette di ottenere grafene in forma di
polvere questa polvere può essere poi
dispersa all'interno di un liquido e
quindi creare degli inchiostri polvere
inchiostri possono essere poi combinati
con materiali che utilizziamo nella
nostra vita di tutti i giorni donandogli
quindi le proprie caratteristiche quindi
rendendoli per esempio più performanti o
con nuove proprietà
oggi abbiamo una scarpa che è
termicamente più confortevole perché
grazie all'aggiunta del grafene nel suo
letto
questo è reso capace dissipare calore
maniera più efficace e quindi di dare un
comfort termico maggiore al nostro piede
ma non solo abbiamo un casco che grazie
al grafene reso più sicuro e
termicamente più confortevole perché
capace di assorbire meglio agli urti e
dissipare meglio il calore che può
essere accumulato per esempio per
l'esposizione al sole
abbiamo anche dei pneumatici più
biciclette che grazie al grafene
presente nella mescola possono per
esempio garantire una maggiore aderenza
una maggior resistenza la foratura una
maggior velocità o dell'abbigliamento
sportivo che grazie a grafene
termicamente più confortevole
antibatterico elettrostatico questi sono
solo alcuni esempi ma sono tutti i
prodotti made in italy è ancora tanto si
sta facendo nei laboratori tante
tecnologie abate grafene si stanno
sviluppando e presto potrebbero arrivare
sul mercato
forse qualcuno di voi riconoscerà il
piccolo robottino aicab stiamo
sviluppando dei compositi che grazie al
grafene possono essere leggeri e
resistenti per sostituire almeno in
parte le strutture metalliche è quello
compongono questo gli permetterebbe di
essere più leggero quindi più leggero
significa meno consumi e quindi
significa che gli potremmo dare una
maggiore autonomia con le batterie di
cui dispone e renderlo anche meno
costoso ma non solo stiamo lavorando
della carta o dei tessuti che grazie al
grafene possono essere resi capaci di
condurre elettricità e quindi
utilizzabili come elettrodi o schermi
elettromagnetici ma sottili
flessibili a basso costo eventualmente
anche biodegradabili o a delle batterie
che possono essere rese grazie grazie ai
più performanti ed eventualmente anche
flessibili questi sono solo alcuni
esempi
moltissime altre cose si stanno facendo
ci stiamo lavorando e molte altre ancora
sono tecnologie su cui bisognerà
lavorare in futuro fare innovazione non
è facile è un percorso lungo e faticoso
trasformare delle idee delle ricerche
scientifiche nei prodotti è un percorso
veramente difficile richiede tanto tempo
ma può veramente cambiare le nostre vite
e ci riguarda più da vicino di quanto
potete immaginare è più che mai in
questo momento storico può diventare
un'occasione di rilancio per le nostre
aziende
il grafene è un'occasione è un esempio
di innovazione in corso l'italia è in
prima fila
non so voi ma io non vedo l'ora di
svoltare le prossime pagine vedere dove
ci porterà e vedere quali altri capitoli
entusiasmanti si potranno scrivere con
la punta di una matita
grazie a tutti
[Applauso]